♪ ♪
>> Tucker: YOUFTEN HEAR
POLITICIANBRAG ABOUT THEIR
PUBLIC SERVICE AND SUCH A
SACRIFICE.
YET NANCY PELOSS CAREER
SUGGESTS MAYBE YOU MISSED HER
CALLING.
SHE SPENT THREE DECADES IN
CONGRESS AND YET SOMEHOW
NCY PELOSI IS WORTH TENS OF
MILLIONS OFOLLARS.
HOW DID S GET SO RICH?
HER HBAND OPERATES AN
INSTMENT FIRM A HE'S MET A
LOT OF REMARBLY WELL-TIMED
TRADES OVER THE YEARS.
THE OTHER YEAR, HE MADE ANOTHER
ONE.
HENAPPED UP BETWEEN
1,000,005,000,00 WORTH IN STOCK
OF A SEMICONCTOR
COMPANY.
TURNS OUT CONGRESS IS VOTI ON
A SUBSIDY TO THE MICONDUCTOR
DUSTRY.
CHARLES A SENIOR CRESPONDENT
WITH FOX BUSINESS A JOINS US
TO ASSESS.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
ISHERE ANY WAY TO GET PAULPELOSS
THE TRADE?
>> THI DUDES A RISING STAR ON
WALL STREET.
THEY GOT NOTHINGN THIS GUY.
HE'S REMARBLE.
HERE THE THING, TUCKER, ITBRINGE
INDER TRADING AND GIVE TIPS?
E SEC AND THE DOJ BROUGHT
SES ON INSIDER TIPS VIA PILLOW
TALK.
ION'T BELIEVE THIS HITS THE
INSIDER TRADING BAR.
A LOT OF THE INFORMATION AUT
THE LESLATIONS BOUNCING
AROUND
IT HAS TBE MATERIAL,
NONPUBLIC, MAPPROPRIATED.
IT DOESN'T HIT THE BARRIERS.BUTM
ARROGANCE ON STEIDS.
KNOWS HE HAS AN INFORMATION
EDGE.
NOSAYING IT'S ILLEGAL, BUT HE
KNOWS HE H INFORMAON.HE AND HIST
STUFF.
HE KNOWS WHAT'S MING DOWN THE
PE AND HE'S GOT SOURCES AND
NOT JUST HER.
IT'S REALLY DISGUSTING LOOKING
AND YOU WANT TO UNDERSTAN WHY
PEOPLE DISTRUST GOVERNMENT IS
BECAUSE OF STUFF LIKE TS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
NOT BECAUSE SOME DIGNITARY
WENT TO THE TRUMP HOTEL, I WROTE
TONS OF STORIES WH
DONALD TRUMP WASRESIDENT.
TRYING TO AND CUDDL UP TO THE
DONALD TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
NO, THIS IS THE BAD STUFF,
GETTINAN EDGE, KNOWING IT
FLIES IN THE FACE OF FAIRNESS.
I'M NOT SAYING IT'S ILLEL AND
AS A MATTER OF FACT DON'T
THINK IT'S ILLEGALASED ON WHAT
I KNOW ONNSIDER TRADING, BUT
IT LOOKSIKE.
Tucker: JUST PUT IT IN A
BLIND TRUST B THEY WON'T.
>> IT'S HYPOCRISY, AND F
SOMEONE WHO LECTURE US ONHE
EVILS  CAPITALISM, IT'S RE